the multiverse, every existence multiplied by possibility and spread out an infinite
measure now there is a malevolent force
at work one driven by a singular goal
the destruction of all there is
there's a wave of antimatter sweeping
across this universe destroying
everything in its path I brought you all
to earth 38 because this is where the
monitor wants you to make your stand
right so we are going to need a bigger
team you want some help the entire
universe needs you across space and time
exist seven heroes who can save the
multiverse I'll find him
you are Clark Kent right? Bruce? Kate?
we need your help to stop this
antimatter wave all right then flash
has the planet been evacuated yet not
entirely then it's not time
one ting is certain everything we know
everything there is and everything there
ever was is doomed
welcome back everyone is Charlie we have a brand new crisis on Infinite Earths
trailer it's supposed to be the final
really big trailer but they'll probably
a couple more promos there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs we had a whole
bunch more footage of Tom Welling
Smallville Superman implying that he's
going to be one of the Paragons all the
crossover episodes will start airing
next Sunday so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything of course I'll do Easter Egg
videos for all the episodes careful for
spoilers for things that have happened
on the other shows so far because I'll
be talking about that stuff but the big
deal here is the monitor finally
explaining the multiverse in crisis on
Infinite Earths to all the people
previously he just been assembling
heroes and pushing them around like
chess pieces on a board he never
mentions the anti-monitor by name he
just refers to him as this malevolent
force behind the antimatter way that's
going to destroy everything like Tom
Cavanagh is pariah wells at the end of
the trailer says one thing's for certain
we're all doomed
they literally destroy supergirls earth
because a lot of this is all taking
place on her earth so that might be one
of the big cliffhanger moments as the
trailer footage plays out it looks like
the next big world on the chopping block
is this version of Argo city where
Cara's mother played by Erica Durance
was that was also where this version of
Superman and his Lois Lane went for the
birth of Superboy Jon Kent that we saw
in the last trailer good thing they came
back to earth 38 just in time but
because of the way they cut this trailer
it's kind of hard to figure out where
all these scenes are happening in the
first three episodes because of some of
the characters that show up I know some
of this footage is from the third
episode it's not all from the first
episode but the reason why I the
Harbinger is probably telling them that
the monitor wants them to make their
stand on earth 38 supergirls earth is
because Supergirl is the first episode
of the crossover this Sunday as you see
during the trailer though things do not
go too well for them they're completely
doomed so it sounds like whatever it is
they're trying to do it's not successful
Oliver talking about getting a few more
people for their team is probably
something from the first episode though
because then you see Barry's show up in
a completely different scene do you guys
need some help there's a bunch of
footage of Earth 90 Barry Allen John
Wesley Shipp in the other trailer he
only shows up at the end of this trailer
too so there's a lot of people that
aren't in this trailer that will show up
during the first couple of episodes this
footage of Oliver asking earth 38
Superman for his help seems kind of
weird where they put it in the trailer
because most versions
of Superman would be the first persons
to leave the charge normally it would be
Superman going around collecting all
these heroes there on the Waverider so
maybe this is them taking the way
brighter to Argo City before it gets
destroyed to pick him up like hey this
is big crisis coming that you don't know
about because you've been on vacation
with your wife who just gave birth to
your new son the monitor explains the
seven Paragons there was a scene during
the flash that kind of teased that -
with pariah Welles that I'll talk about
in a second but as far as I know that
Paragons are supposed to be Oliver the
flash or 38 Superman Tom Wellings
Smallville Superman as this footage
implies kingdom comes Superman who
doesn't really show up that much during
this trailer Martian Manhunter and Kevin
Conroy is Batman but there's a
difference between being one of the main
characters of the air / shows and being
a Paragon so not all the mains are
supposed to be Paragons if there's only
going to be seven Paragons in the way they cut this trailer implies that a bunch of
non main characters will also be
Paragons like it's implied that earth 38
Lex Luthor is also one of the Paragons
big twist that one of the big villains
is also supposed to be one of the big
heroes of crisis because he's such a
genius
and he can help them out love the
footage of Superman and iris going to
get Smallville Superman who just seems
completely chagrin to see them like what
what is going on here if you never read
smallville season 11 the comic book
tells the story of what happens to him
after the Smallville series finale when
he fully becomes Superman and he puts
the suit on there's a version of Justice
League on this earth there's a version
of Batman Wonder Woman most of the other big Superman specific comic book
characters and Justice League characters
he has all these adventures with them
we're not quite 10 years out from the
Smallville series finale but Marc
Guggenheim the showrunner on arrow in
one of the executive producers and
managers sort of this big crossover
endeavor said that they would be
treating the smallville season 11 comic
like canon for the purposes of the
crossover so when they show up on this
earth
that's why Smallville Superman looks
like he's none the worse for wear got a
whole lot of city miles on that version
of Superman one of the other most
interesting things that they do in this
trailer is canonised Kevin Conroy is
Kingdom Come looking Batman as the
Batman of Earth one at least that's what
they're implying based on this
interaction because he instantly
recognizes bat woman as if it's his
version of Kate Cain his niece that he's
known this whole time I'm totally cool
with them doing this meaning that Kevin
Conroy has been the bat
man of Earth 1 this entire time we just
haven't known it till now the
alternative would have been to have him
come from another earth my biggest
question for him now is how are they
going to treat all the Batman the Animated Series and Batman Beyond Easter eggs
since that's where most people know
Kevin Conroy from and typically what
they've done with big actors like this
from other DC properties is they try to
include Easter eggs from the places that
they came from but because this is a
live-action now it's getting really meta
you just have to pretend like what if
Batman the Animated Series had been a
live-action show that would be one of
the best DC shows of all time because
Batman the Animated Series is not just
one of the best animated series of all
time it is one of the best TV shows of
all time just by itself we finally see
all those shadow demons that they teased
in Nora's future newspaper during the
flash season 5 obviously these are all
CG creations which is why they did
include been the previous trailers
because they're still working on all the
visual effects reverse-flash was
supposed to be leading this army so
maybe he shows up right before this big
battle happens in whichever episode that
winds up being the reason we probably
haven't seen them is because they've
been spending most of their time in
these trailers focusing on the pariah
version of Welles and Tom Cavanagh is
playing all these different characters
if you look in this big bite scene
there's all these pillars and pylons
with advanced looking technology
bursting through the floorboards in this
regular looking Lobby so this probably
has something to do with the monitors
cosmic tuning forks the big towers that
they construct during comic book crisis
on Infinite Earths it's just part of his
plan to try and stop the antimatter wave
but as we see it looks like it's
completely unsuccessful also notice that
Ray Palmer is in most of the early
footage on earth 38 and kingdom comes
Superman Brandon Ralph is in all the
later footage so unless this blue energy
that just winks him out is portaling him
somewhere else
early our IP - Ray Palmer this shot of
Superman a Supergirl against the red sky
is also interesting because they're
using their powers and you think that
the yellow Sun being blotted out by the
red antimatter wave would dampen them in some way the whole reason why you would
want to turn the sky red would be to
neutralize them Barry gets really
curious about some weird-looking cosmic
energy that we haven't seen before this
is Sarah in what looks like Lois Lane in
the white jacket in the future team
arrow bunker where everything is run
down then flash recruits black lightning
on the wave
that's not happening till episode 3 he
might show up at the tail end of episode
2 in a tag scene or something like that
then everybody press F in the chat for
Earth 38 the monitor did tease that he
can bring Earth's back that have been
wipes but it would be cool if they use
Crysis Earth's will live Earth's will
die and the universe will never be the
same
to merge super girls show with the earth
1 characters that way all the heroes can
be on earth 1 we already have our earth 1
Batman now canonized as Kevin Conroy
so you basically have all your big
Justice League characters - a Wonder
Woman although I do believe they've been
trying to get Lynda Carter in a cameo so
that may have happened because they
finished filming the crossover a while
ago so for those of you asking about
that tag scene where he became pariah
from the comics they just confirmed some
of the theories that we had earlier this
season it just made sense based on his
mission of trying to attain this
knowledge and take down the monitor that
he would be turned into comic book
pariah the whole idea here is that he
gained access to the secret sanctum
these seven symbols correlate to the
seven different Paragons although it's
not clear which symbol correlates to
which Paragon but when the voices the
monitor grants him access and you see
the door open and he's bathed in this
light that just blots him out that's him
attaining this cosmic knowledge my next
video will be for the mid-season finale
of the flash they'll be teeing up crisis
and wrapping up their negative flash art
but while you wait for everything click
here for that brand new Black Widow
trailer and click here for the other big
crisis on Infinite Earths trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome and see you guys tonight